hi-yah he's going for it
guy little fella dies hello my name's
Anne Jones and today we're going to be
looking at viral videos of kangaroos
take away skip
[Music]
i am i saw this on facebook recently
[Music]
skippy is like the Australian kangaroo
version lassie you Skippy I read they
used to use like 15 kangaroos to do two
stunts every single episode device skips
it's going across a creek he's undoing a
bolts oh he's on a boat it's pretty good
judge Strummer absolute blessing
Australian and television news if you go
back and look carefully Eric and you're
gonna be able to see a human hand
controlling a Skippy hand there Skippy
the truth I don't know that Skippy would
be able to help you if you're being held
by international bandits and I don't
know that you'd be able to pass you a
wrench when you're fixing up your car
the small one Skippy is an Eastern grey
kangaroo and she's a macro pod that
means big-footed all kangaroos fall into
this family but really they could have
been called micro hands because they've
got those tiny little forearms and these
little scratchy paws on the end of it
and while they do have a little bit of
dexterity they can you know scrape
little holes they can sort of maneuver
some objects when they're close to them
but I don't think that Skippy would be
able to actually you know crack a safe
or you know start a car that noise is a
little bit like the the dolphin noises
that we think that flipper was making
entirely fictional they grunt gone up
gotta get okay
gopher running towards us he's getting
chased by one I think that perhaps that
kangaroo may have been being fed and he
might think that humans feed him it
doesn't seem to be aggressive behavior
they're much more like stand their
ground when it comes to aggression it's
probably confused but that guy is
throwing a wobbly over nothing you'd be
able to see they can't go to him right
by the side of the field I've got a bit
of a soccer game going on and an
extremely muscular and worried kangaroo
hopping around the hop is actually
really efficient they're the only
animals in the world that get around
like this oh okay
interesting so licking your forearms in
kangaroos is something they do when
they're hot and bothered
they can't sweat like we can so you know
how dogs pant when they're hot kangaroos
lick their forearms and that provides
evaporative cooling and racing across
the field of play scattering players
left and right look at how fast it's
going
I love that there's a couple of the
soccer players that are absolutely
terrified of it and sprint in the other
direction
kangaroos can jump up to seven meters in
one hop and the faster they go the
bigger their hop so it's they don't do
more hops to go really fast they just
leap more and more all right we've got
some horse racing going didn't do too
bad to get through that without getting
himself killed
the kangaroo can go like 50 K and our
rights that's really fast he won't have
any trouble getting off that course as
long as he's not injured because he can
jump a fence that's like two meters high
so you're going to see him again he's
gone he's gone to place a bit like
Skippy to get away from the bookie
Skippy okay we've got a kangaroo in the
ocean
so you might not know this that
kangaroos can actually swim so can I
keep this he might have been threatened
chased by dogs so he took to the water
to get rid of them okay so we've got a
creek and it looks to me like it could
be a swamp wallaby which is a smaller
type of macro pod
this is classic evasion behavior one of
the great things about macro pods and
its really surprising is we see them
hopping like this on land right so
they're big back feet go bulk bulk and
hit the ground at exactly the same time
but when they're in the water they can
use them individually and do sort of
like a doggy paddle so it's really
fascinating they don't do that on land
like you don't see them walking around
like strutting but under the water they
can go like this how cool are these
videos there's so many surprising things
they can swim they can play soccer they
like horse racing they even play jazz
drums I mean can you think of something
that they couldn't do you could they be
the next Prime Minister of Australia
maybe they could
do you love watching animal videos as
much as I do
and if you've got an idea for an animal
video why don't you send it in to us or
leave a comment below anyway until next
time catch you later
[Music]